the moment India's Supreme Court upheld
the government's decision to strip
Indian administered jamu and Kashmir of
special status and ordered new elections
in the region by the end of September
next year restoration of statehood shall
take place at the earliest and as soon
as
possible it was a decision welcomed by
prime minister Narendra Modi as well as
Hardline Hindu nationalists Jammu
Kashmir is integral part of India there
cannot be two flags and two
constitution in Jammu and kashmir's
capital shagar the response from
politicians was one of
disappointment this is the defeat of
this nation the Supreme Court has
betrayed us but we have not by calling
article 370 temporary they have weakened
this
nation since 1947 jamu and Kashmir has
been at the heart of a bitter dispute
between India and neighboring Pakistan a
conflict forged as both Nations gained
independence from British colonial rule
the Muslim majority territory is claimed
by both countries and has been a point
of violent
struggle under India's Constitution
Article 370 had conferred separate
status on the territory for nearly 70
years revoking that had been modi's key
campaign promise in
2019 sending a clear sign to supporters
of his intention to integrate the
territory into the rest of India Sonia
Gago Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer